is here to get us in the saint patrick's
day spirit so let's welcome bar
supervisor dan love to introduce us to a
cocktail that'll make anyone feel like
the luck of the irish right anybody you
make me feel like i'm irish today oh
yeah
so we're featuring the whistler irish
cream which is an absolutely delicious
whiskey
whiskey is the main ingredient patrick's
day right oh yeah special richies i love
it
a little bit so richie's uh irish pub we
specialize in all kinds of different
whiskeys we have an awesome whiskey club
which jameson's going to tell you about
your name is jameson it has to be how
did that happen
as well yeah so dan was talking about
what we call the century club which we
have a rich making leaves it's really
what sets us apart from your typical
irish pub is that we have an app that
allows you to track your whiskey drinks
that you've had at our you know
establishment and move your way up the
leaderboard there wow yeah so it's right
and also keep track of how many you've
had yeah exactly it's very unique it's
uh you know it's it's an exclusive club
but uh you know we have quite a few
members and we're growing we expect to
add a few more this thursday because
whiskey you know whiskey is not just an
alcoholic beverage it is an art form
it's something very decadent right yes
you guys take your whiskey seriously oh
yeah and i mean it's got one of the best
histories of any of the spirits around
the world
deep history it's got a great history in
ireland it's got a great history here in
america
so um just talk a little bit about their
cocktail today um that's just making it
easiest can be even after a long night
at st paddy's day
it's just equal parts so richie's we do
an ounce and a half of each okay you put
them in a tin you add ice you shake it
up all right of course you gotta do that
oh my gosh and this is hot this has
espresso in it this is like oh yeah oh
yeah espresso martini
exactly this is vibe
oh i'm so ready what am i gonna what are
the flavors what are the textures i'm
gonna be having here so at first you're
gonna notice just the texture as far as
the mouth tastes it's gonna be nice
creamy delicious it's gonna go down
really easy
and you get real subtle hints of whiskey
it's not gonna be overpowering it's
really approachable for people who are
not that's good for me yeah good for me
[Applause]
thank you and as we have
as we cheers to st patrick's day and a
nice drink let's talk about the patio
party you guys are having yes so we're
partnering with our sister property
parkway tavern it's right next to us at
the district we're gonna be throwing an
all-day party
dangerous because it's so good so good
yeah
it starts in the morning it's gonna go
through until you know the wee hours and
the next morning we got all kinds of
activations and you know live music djs
it's going to be a lot of fun we're
extending our patio out to make it even
bigger awesome it's like a half block
party right yes
and we actually we actually brought in a
couple pub crawls we're going to have
guinness girls are going to be there so
it's going to be
an all-day party that is definitely
going to be felt the next day for sure
okay and um there's also food on the
menu right you guys are just filling us
up with drinks you guys also have irish
food for irish menu yes of course we you
know it's st patrick's day but it's
always saint patrick's day richard
mcneely so i like that i like irish food
plus appetizers we got you know
obviously 200 whiskeys but we also have
other cocktails as well if you're
interested in those too we'll definitely
get this one guys
everything you want to try everything
but this is good i can tell you from
experience yes thank you cheers